the most precious thing in the world is
the financial security and well-being of
your family you want to send your little
ones to the best schools and in the end
know that you've left them with peace of
mind
nowadays we all know that cash rules
everything around us cream get the money
dollar dollar bill y'all that's why it's
time to enter the 36 change in step to
the rule wu-tang financial at wu-tang
financial we'll work with you to devise
the best plan for you and your fam
you got no objective you gotta play this
game well and I mean hand out get grab
punk you need to diversify your bonds
nigga you're not about to go to war
invest in some nuclear bombs this ain't
trading places nigga this is real like
take your goddamn night okay financial
peace with you and your kids all of our
trusted consultants are here to meet
your needs
unfortunately the old dirty bastard
couldn't make it today but he soon is
because so call us because at the end of
the day we can
nothing
[Applause]
step to the moon we pain primates